let me just use this opportunity to
condemn john cena john cena if you're
listening to this podcast you are a
scoundrel you're supposed to be a tough
guy that's your entire brand and china
criticizes you and you get on your hands
and knees and bark like a dog show some
backbone i challenge you john cena to
come on this podcast with me and let's
have the conversation about china
so you were one of the first guys to
really get onto the lab leak story where
are we at with that now 18 months hence
yeah so i'll start in the beginning it
was late january of last year like
everybody else i was deeply concerned
about this emerging pandemic and
thinking well where does this come from
and like most people i thought well it
sounds pretty similar to the last sars
outbreak which we knew happened
uh and it came from nature through
markets but then in late january of last
year i saw
a report in the lancet which showed that
more than a third of the
earliest people being infected
um had no contact with that now
infamous uh seafood market in uh in
wuhan
um and then i i kind of had i have two
perspectives one as a person who's
deeply immersed in the world of science
and another as the other part of my life
deeply immersed in asia and china and
geopolitics
and so something just didn't feel right
when the chinese government
kept talking about a market origin
when it was pretty clear to me that the
evidence suggested otherwise
and then i just started digging i really
i dove in and the more i learned the
more the questions were raised about the
possibility of a lab incident origin and
it's still not 100 proven
that that's where this pandemic um comes
from um but the circumstantial evidence
is just incredibly strong and everything
we learn at least it seems to me that
it's that it's getting stronger so yeah
we'll dig into the details of this but
uh where we are now
uh is in my mind there's a very strong
but still circumstantial case suggesting
a very likely uh but not certain lab
incident origin of the pandemic
china and is really just outrageously
preventing
any kind of
investigation into the origins of the
pandemic they're still engaged in just a
massive and outrageous cover-up
involving destroying samples hiding
records imprisoning people in china for
asking questions they have a gag order
preventing chinese scientists from
saying or writing anything about
pandemic origins without prior
government approval
there are some efforts to dig deeper but
we need we need a lot more is that not
likely to be potentially the most
evidence that we get
the purely coincidental anecdotal this
is what it seems because
if the chinese government continues to
stumble as effectively as it is at the
moment then
maybe we're never actually going to find
out anything that's concrete it's all
just going to be
best case scenarios well that that could
be that's one possibility but we also
have to think of how much we and by we i
mean a bunch of wees there's certainly
our group it's called the quote-unquote
the paris group a group of about two
dozen experts around the world who've
been collaborating on this issue since
uh last year
there's another group and and there's
some overlap between our our two groups
called drastic
which is a group of
they're called internet salutes but
they're they're more than that um who've
been digging
and and we have uncovered and this
community
more broadly has uncovered a lot of
highly highly relevant information that
has told us a lot
about this this story so yes it would be
better if china had complete
transparency but there's a lot that we
can do
and most people
most people will be surprised
that there's still
no comprehensive international
investigation into the origins of the
pandemic and what that means is if
you're somebody in china maybe a
scientist who has highly relevant
information i'm sure you're scared for
your life
or right now
there's and you wanted to share that
information there's not even an address
there's there are no secure
whistleblower
provisions so there's much more that we
can do will it work will it get us to
100 certainty
maybe it will maybe it won't but we
can't say it won't before we even try
why is there no investigation
it's been a political process
and the main reason is that china has
blocked it
last year in early 2020 australian prime
minister scott morrison called for a
full investigation
after he did that the chinese government
punished australia by imposing trade
sanctions to try to deliver the message
uh that anybody who dares to ask
questions will be punished
um he and the australians brought that
idea to the world health assembly which
is the governing board overseeing the
world health organization in may of last
year
and there was a jujitsu move by the the
chinese and the europeans played a role
in this as well
and so this idea for a full
investigation
into the origins of the pandemic morphed
into a chinese-supported resolution
which mandated essentially a
chinese-controlled joint international
chinese study not into the origins of
the pandemic but into the single
hypothesis
of a natural
origin not associated with a lab
incident so that
led to the just the farce
of this international joint study group
that then the international members went
to wuhan in in january of 20
2021 this year
in early february they held just a
farcical press conference
where in wuhan where they basically
repeated chinese propaganda lines it
comes from nature maybe it comes from
frozen food they said which was
preposterous and they were just later
admitted they were just doing that as a
favor to the chinese
and then
the lead spokesman for this
international
expert team independent expert team
he said we've concluded that a lab
incident origin is extremely unlikely
and doesn't merit further investigation
and it later turned out he admitted he
was lying that wasn't what he thought he
was just doing he had done a back room
horse trading deal with the chinese who
didn't want a lab incident mentioned at
all so he said all right well i'll say
it's extremely unlikely i'll say
it shouldn't be investigated but is it
okay if we just mention a lab incident
and as i understand
that person is actually under
investigation by the who for doing this
kind of deal i was going to say it's so
crazy that there is no
uh further level of authority that can
look to try and impose on this
particular group when you talk about
an entire global event
each individual nation state kind of
looks after itself but we don't there's
no uh what was that team america there's
no one that's like the global police
that's flying around and trying to
enforce this stuff and um yeah i mean
you know i'm not advocating for a new
world order or a you know one nation
state across the entire world but we are
seeing here that there is a
lack of recourse when it's nation state
versus nation state because the only
thing that you have to play with are
like trade sanctions and threats of war
and all sorts of stuff like that which
seems kind of primitive
yeah yeah
that's 100 right and really accurate and
so um the leadership of the world health
organization they're now trying to do as
as much as they can
they have created a group called sago
the scientific advisory group
for
investigating the origins of novel
pathogens and that was kind of a a
really bold move by dr tedros and the
who leadership
to supersede the mandate that had been
given to them by the the world health
assembly he was basically their bosses
of the of the states and so that's
happening now but china has essentially
condemned uh the dr tedros and efforts
to to and what he's called for a full
audit of wuhan labs and access to the
raw data
and china has clearly said that they're
not going to allow that and
and their participation in a lot of
these international organizations
isn't designed to strengthen the
organizations but to blunt and and block
them and that's that's really uh really
concerning
right now as we speak uh the there's a
special session of the world health
assembly uh that is meeting to negotiate
what what will likely take many years
which is a new pandemic treaty uh
because it's just a hundred percent
clear
that the institutions and structures
that we have in place right now
for responding to this kind of crisis
are massively insufficient but
ironically after the first tsars uh in
the in 2003 2004 where china had a
similar kind of cover-up in the early
stages
we had the same meeting said we need to
have stronger structures we built them
through the international health
regulations and then it didn't make a
difference as matter of fact china's
behavior this time is even worse it's
even more atrocious
and that leads to your broader question
about just how the world is is organized
and
as you know i'm the founder of an
organization called one shared world and
what we're trying to do is to address
exactly what you said there's a mismatch
between
the nature of the biggest problems that
we face which are global and common
and the absence
of sufficient structures for addressing
that entire category of problems and
that's pandemics climate change
proliferating nuclear weapons and and
lots of
of other things
uh and that's why uh china in the name
of national sovereignty
is able to do all these these things
that certainly i find despicable not
just covering up the origins of the
pandemic
but also committing mass human rights
abuses in xinjiang and tibet and
illegally seizing territory in the south
china sea and along the border with
india
and elsewhere
and that's why we really really need to
think deeply
about how do we build a safer structure
for uh for the world
and if we don't do it unfortunately our
world's going to become a much more much
more dangerous place so that's why
we need to start moving in that
direction it's not just about what
states can do everybody has a role yeah
there definitely needs to be more
oversight that's a really interesting
way to actually look at concluding
what's happened to the lab league theory
whether it was zoonotic at a wet market
whether it was a lab leak or whether it
was something else
china is covering up the origin of the
virus it doesn't matter what side of
this debate you fall on
everybody can accept the fact that
trania china isn't being transparent
with the single biggest global health
problem that we've had in the modern era
and that's that blows my mind there's no
recourse for us to try and get those
people back it's it's crazy
it's really terrible and what china will
say and does say about issues of
xinjiang and and tibet and others is
well the human rights of chinese people
um that's china's own business the rest
of the world isn't a stakeholder
but the rest of the world is a
stakeholder the fact that the
whistleblowers weren't able to speak out
in the earliest days following the
outbreak whatever the origin of the
outbreak the the fact that people
chinese people who are asking questions
are in prison uh one of them zhang is
actually near death
in in prison that's not just a chinese
issue i mean uh the economist estimates
that the number of total dead is
due to covet is between 15 and 16
million
i would venture to say that a ver
regardless of the of the origin a very
significant percentage of those deaths
are attributable
to the pathologies of the chinese state
and to this cover-up
so what's been some of the new
realizations that have come out has
there been any data that's arrived
recently updates with regards to the
origin of covid oh huge and and a lot
has has come out and first let me just
lay on on the table the two cases the
people who believe this has a natural
origin they will argue
that that's how most uh pandemics have
happened in the past
and
nature is is very creative and so we
just can't say what what will or will
not show up the counter argument which
is certainly what i believe is far more
likely um is that we have an outbreak of
a uh of a bat with a horseshoe uh with
them sorry of a virus with a horseshoe
bat uh backbone it happens not where the
horseshoe bats are but more than a
thousand miles away where they don't
have this kind of horseshoe bats but
they have the uh the world's a
china's first and largest uh highest
level uh virology institute high
containment lab with the world's largest
collection of bat coronaviruses where
they were doing research not even at the
highest level at bsl 3 and 2
levels
designed to make these scary viruses
even scarier we'll leave the word gain
of function aside for a moment
and then on this
virus shows up and on day one it's uh
with no
parent so far evolutionary history it's
ready uh to
easily pass
from human uh human to human um
and then they have the whole the whole
cover-up since the earliest days of the
outbreak we've had a lot more
information people in drastic uncovered
information that was being hidden by the
chinese about a copper mine in yunnan in
southern china in 2012 six miners were
sent down to clean out uh bad guano bad
manure
all of them got sick with what uh look
today very much like sorry like covet 19
symptoms
um half of them died their blood samples
were taken to the wuhan institute of
virology and elsewhere uh multiple
sampling trips
were sent to this this same mine
and in those sampling trips uh
a number of many different viruses were
collected
including um one that is among the most
genetically similar to sars cov2 and
because there's a lot of recombination
in bat viruses just have to assume um
that similarity breeds similarity so
it's quite likely that that there are
additional similar viruses in the
in the collection uh then the wuhan
institute of virology's viral database
with um 22 000 samples
vanished it first went offline and then
vanished in late 2019 and that was also
uh dug up
then we got had access to this
organization eco health alliance which
was a funding partner to wuhan institute
of virology
and they
were engaged in all sorts of activities
that certainly from the perspective of
now seem uh seem questionable
then i could just go on forever but i
won't i then we just
found out through a leak and a leak that
i think was a deliberate leak from the
u.s defense department that said hey we
did the right thing
but that
in march of 2018 so a year and a half
before
the outbreak uh this organization eco
health alliance along with the wuhan
institute of
virology
applied for 14 million dollars of darpa
funding and one of the things that they
wanted to do
was to genetically engineer a furin
cleavage site which is part of the spike
protein basically how these viruses are
able to and best infect human cells if
you're in cleavage site
into
uh the backbone of a sars-like virus and
so the wuhan institute of virology was
going to collect the viruses and they
did collect viruses from laos cambodia
southern china and elsewhere and this la
this work was supposed to be done at the
university of north carolina in the the
lab
of ralph barrack
darpa correctly
rejected that proposal but there's a
real question is did the chinese go
forward anyway i think it's actually
quite likely and that's basically in in
most fields of advanced science that's
what the chinese are doing they'll
partner with international experts to
learn as much as they need to learn and
then they'll just push forward
doing that thing in china that's why the
first crispr babies were born in china
and lots of
and lots of other things so we're we're
really
learning a lot and the more we learn uh
the more this looks like um it's very
likely a lab incident origin and and the
reason why uh we have this pandemic
it's the origin probably but not
conclusively a lab incident origin and
then as we said regardless of the origin
a criminal cover-up
was what exacerbated this crisis and
brought it to scale would you say that
kovids helped china overall have they
suffered more than other countries how
does that work out yeah so i think
relatively china is better off china's
relative power is stronger now china is
relatively stronger now than it was in
the beginning that doesn't mean it's
been an enjoyable experience for them by
by any means
but to china's credit
they've managed the spread
of the virus inside of of china
certainly more than than has any other
big country
some people
suggest so that raises the question of
could this have been deliberate i don't
think it is i mean these are really
smart people it's like the dumbest thing
ever would be to say we're gonna release
a dangerous highly infectious um
pathogen
in our you know one of our big cities
with the goal of infecting our city
first and then the rest of the world
will do a better job of of locking i
don't think that's that's very likely
but i do think most likely there was
some kind of accident followed by a
criminal cover-up yeah that crosses the
line from uh aggressive and sometimes
negligent to malicious and mostly
psychotic
yes yeah which well yeah i agree i mean
and so
you you start out at uh negligent and
certainly ambitious and and negligent um
but then you get to the criminal
cover-up um and that's
that's the thing and the cover-up is
malicious because lots of countries uh
make mistakes uh the united states we
had union carbide we had three mile
island we had the accidental bombing of
the beijing embassy in in belgrade uh
recently there was a a terrible
seemingly accidental uh killing of of a
family and in afghanistan there was the
whole afghanistan debacle lots of
countries make mistakes i'm not
pinpointing china as the only country to
make a mistake or as the only country to
ever have a cover-up but what i am
saying
in this case um it's it's
the consequences are pretty awful so
taking a broader view
what's china's
overall
goal
at the moment for the nation what do
they want
well
i'll just put it in their terms i mean
what the the chinese strategic documents
have said is they're looking to have
global leadership uh by the year 2049
which is the 100th anniversary of the
of the chinese state the the chinese
revolution what's going on what's global
leadership and where did they say this
so
right now uh do historically uh china
has seen itself as the middle kingdom
it's it's certainly
a or one maybe the great civilization of
its region and they had a relationship
with the countries around it that was
based on that understanding which is
very very different from the principles
of the post-war international order that
were established by the united states
and the uk and our allies in the
aftermath of the of the second world war
and so china would like to have that
freedom of maneuver china sees
the united states
i think as a country that's trying to
keep china down and sees that post-war
liberal international order as something
that is just a veiled threat it's not
something designed for the common good
but something designed to keep others
down and as they see it keep uh the
united states um in the in a role of
of primacy and they want to get out of
that and part of getting out of that at
least in my view
is deeply undermining this system the
alliance system
that emboldens
uh countries
like
japan and korea and australia to stand
up to uh to china that doesn't
necessarily mean that china wants to
militarily take over the world china
says they never take over um other
entities but that's just a
bald-faced lie because you just have to
have it just a different view of they
give you if i were to say america is the
whole world
then america would never invade any
other country because i had just
declared that all other countries are
america if china just says the entire
south china sea is china
then seizing territory in the south
china sea isn't aggression it's just
this is this this is our so they they
usually it's the big brother little
brother stop hitting yourself
thing all over again isn't it stop
hitting yourself
something like that but the thing is
for them um yeah i mean for them they're
just making declarations i mean that
that's why
uh for china managing the information
space is so important because the idea
is well just just declare some big crazy
thing
and then start defending that crazy
thing and then you act according to that
principle and then people will say hey
you're wrong and you say oh no no
we we have a claim to the entire south
china sea so this is just uh just a
dispute this isn't aggression we're not
seizing territory we're not attacking
india um we're just
part of this uh of this dispute um where
we haven't uh in xinjiang and and and
tibet uh taiwan uh china has uh the the
the
the government on mainland china has
only controlled taiwan
for four years since 1895
and yet that claim there are lots of
other countries that have a much
stronger claim to other places that have
let bygones be bygones but again china
it
asserts its reality
and then tries to defend
the reality that it's that it's created
what is can you explain what china's
doing in the south china sea with its
little island debts
how it's expanding territory
yes um so um a big vulnerability that
china has is that the united states navy
is
still more advanced and stronger and the
south china sea is one of the
main thoroughfares for trade it's not
it's natural resource risk
rich not just fishing but uh oil and
it's critically important
china has made this just absurd
outlandish and according to
international law illegal claim called
the nine dash line um to essentially the
entire south china sea
and then what they did um is they
claimed these
the essentially reefs in the middle of
the south china sea
seized them and have built massive
military installations uh on those
islands and what they're doing so the
united states has aircraft carrier
battle groups and if you've ever seen
them they're just unbelievably awesome
displays of power um but if you have
military installations right in the
middle of the south china sea
that's like a huge aircraft carrier in
one of the critic most important places
where you would have an aircraft carrier
and
if you have a land base you can really
do a lot and the united states could
neutralize those bases in a war scenario
i mean they're just sitting there so you
could you know attack them in a war
but all most of life and hopefully all
of life happens outside of a war
of a war scenario so it's again it's the
same thing china declares an imaginary
reality and then starts acting as if the
imaginary reality is is real and then
when people raise questions about it
attacks those those people or those
countries isn't there a rule to do with
a particular radius around the island
it's a 90 mile radius or something so by
china picking up these little reefs
they're slowly expanding that territory
because they all intersect it's the
convention of the law of the sea
and these little reefs these little
sunken uh natural structures
don't have i mean one the claims are
totally illegal two even if they were
legal these reefs don't afford that kind
of protection but they take these reefs
and then they're pouring cement and
they're building structures on
on top of them and in order to make
these these claims and and what they're
trying to do is just create realities on
the ground
um that will transform the the
conversation because now they have these
military installations and and they're
they're telling every every other
country
what are you gonna do about it are you
gonna are you gonna force us to leave
and and china has built up its massive
military they're now investing hugely in
hypersonic weapons and nuclear weapons
in attack submarines and so it's not
even clear
that if the united states were to
challenge
those those islands at least at this
stage
and there were some kind of military
confrontation it's not even clear who
who would win so what china's trying to
do
is just change the realities on the
ground regardless of the
of the legalities regardless of what it
does to any concept of a rules-based
international order
and then just say well that's that's the
reality get used to it
they're [ __ ] about with anchoring
bias
and
status quo bias and first mover
advantage better than anyone that i've
ever seen as you say by
proclaiming a particular situation and
then matching reality to that situation
and then saying what do you mean this
this huge concrete building has always
been here on this island it's always
been our territory um i mean
it's not the most subtle of strategies
but it definitely seems like it's being
effective and it's being rolled out it's
across everything right it's whether
you're looking at controlling
information whether you're looking at
the way that they
are restricting dissident conversation
there's this new rule around algorithms
as well they've just made one of the
most restrictive rules on algorithms
ever what's happened there
yeah so my friend matt pottinger has an
editorial in the new york times uh today
on this and basically china has
recognized as many of us have that
data is the new oil of the of the 21st
century and so with china first they
have laws to capture
the data of their own citizens making it
illegal to export that data
but now they're having laws to try to
capture uh the the data of all of
companies that are operating inside of
of china so what china's doing
is building these massive data sets of
of everybody's information inside of
china and outside and there's lots of
theft
of records including i'm assuming my
records because they hack the white
house um office of personnel which has
all of my my former security clearances
and and other things
and then there
there's no doubt um that they're going
to weaponize that information or
certainly utilize to their advantage
over over time and so there's the data
they're the algorithms and china
is certainly playing for keeps they have
a might makes right mentality that
doesn't mean that they're that that
approach is necessarily going to win
but it certainly means that those of us
um in
in elsewhere in the world who don't want
to live in that kind of cyanocentric
rule world a world organized around
those values
we need to organize ourselves we need to
manifest the kind of values and that we
articulate and when we look at what's
happening here in the united states and
what's happening in the uk
and elsewhere it doesn't really look
like that i mean and so yes we we can
and should be critical of what china is
doing and we have to fight back
but one of the ways um
fighting back has to be
reinvesting in our own democracy our own
strength our own
strategic thinking about how do we make
ourselves stronger and
counter the the challenges that we face
globally how much do you think that the
civil discontent in the west at the
moment is legitimate
and how much do you think is
sold by foreign actors like the internet
research agency in russia or
china well we have these debates we have
these divisions and they are mostly
indigenous
but i think that the chinese and and the
russians
and maybe a few others but certainly the
chinese and the russians they are
throwing lighter fluid into this
existing fire
and when you have these kind of critical
turning points um like the the election
of of donald trump and and and certainly
other
experiences that we've experienced here
in the united states uh around racial
tensions and gun rights and abortion uh
they're just throwing this lighter fluid
in into the fire and it's exacerbating
things and that's that's but there's a
challenge because
uh
having a healthy debate even sometimes
uncomfortable uh debate is essential uh
and we have these these new vehicles uh
like twitter
that give a lot of people voice
who haven't had previously voice at this
kind of of scale
but at the same time we need to protect
ourselves against malicious interference
and malicious disinformation campaigns
sowed by
foreign
foreign government actors who are are
wishing us ill and it's it's really hard
hard to do and so we have to both fight
those foreign actors
and i think we need to reinvest in
building a culture of civility a
stronger culture of civility here in the
united states that doesn't mean that we
can't have different uh differences we
we can we should it's natural for us to
do them uh but i think if we just get in
this world we're just breaking into
these blocks and everybody is just
flinging firebombs over their wall at
the other guy um i just think that's
that's not going to be healthy for
anyone the problem is that the
difference between um
indigenously created conflict based on
something that genuinely needs to be
fixed and
foreign actor
created problems that manifest to look
like something that was created
internally though they're essentially
impossible for us to work out and
another thing that i've been thinking
about i've been i mean texas i've been
here for a couple of weeks and
although the atmosphere here is
beautiful from watching uh the the us
from the uk over the last couple of
years
the difference in this sort of
environment and the sort of climate
that's been in the us for the last 18
months
from what actually happened to the kind
of environment that russia or china
would want the us to have if they were
going to try and take this country down
it's it's not that far away you think
about loss of national pride hatred of
the flag uh increased divisions uh lack
of understanding around what truth means
lack of agreement around what truth
means lack of trust in news media lack
of trust in government and political
officials and all that sort of stuff so
to me there's only two
things that could be happening one is
that this is fundamentally being fueled
by foreign actors and they're patting
each other on the back and saying well
done the second one is that they're
maybe throwing a little bit of lighter
fluid on the fire but looking at each
other and going was this
was this us no and they're just clapping
as america turns around and kicks the
ball into its own goal over and over and
over again
yeah i think the second is more likely
and you're right it's it's hard to
measure exactly
what it is because there are a lot of
things that are just changing in our in
our societies so i wouldn't i mean it
would be absurd to say that everything
that's happening all these divisions
it's just china and russia is making us
do it i mean that would take away all of
our agency and and all of our and all of
our responsibilities so i think that we
have to very aggressively counter what
china and russia are doing and very
conveniently both of them are blocking
and protecting their own information
spaces at home and public information
spaces
but again
we also need to reinvest in our own
democracy i think there are a lot of
people who don't feel heard i'm here and
we need to make sure that we have the
that we create forums and and and people
you know we all
interact within structures we're not in
we don't exist in some kind of a vacuum
and and part of those structures are
algorithmic i mean i it's hard for me to
measure this but i was telling this to
somebody else the other day
so i have different parts of my life and
certainly i focus some energy a decent
energy on pandemic origins
and then part on thinking about the
future of the genetics and biotech
revolutions and part on one shared world
and how do we think about building a
better world for everybody
when i when i tweet things like uh we
need to dig into the origins of the
pandemic china's engaged in an illegal
cover-up responsible for millions of
unnecessary deaths we have to demand a
full investigation blah blah blah that
gets a lot of attention if i tweet um we
need to come together to build a safer
world for everybody it's like
two people it's not as fun it's not as
exciting yeah and but so
it could be that that people are just
seeing it and say well i don't care
about building a safer world or it could
be that the algorithm is is somehow
weighting uh different things
differently and so i do think that we
need to think about the structures
in which our communications are
happening because the structures have
inherent biases and it's not that these
are intentional biases it's just that
these these biases play out over time
and then have big implications well
they're reflections of our mentality
right and our psychology the limbic
hijack the fact that if it bleeds it
leads is something that catches our
attention as opposed to some lovely
fluffy aphorism about one love
it's just not going to grab people's
attention in the same way another thing
that i was looking at was anti-us
propaganda have you done much research
into this from china
well certainly there's a lot of anti-us
probably can't say i've done a huge
amount of research but you look all
around the world i mean what china is
essentially trying to do is undermine
the united states and highlight the the
very real failings of of the united
states the united states didn't
monumentally screw up in afghanistan uh
because of china and we did it ourselves
and we have a lot of
self-inflicted wounds and what china is
doing is is both highlighting those
shortcomings and seeking to amplify uh
the things that china actually does
pretty well i mean we have to credit
where credit's due i mean china has
brought hundreds of millions of its own
people out of abject poverty they've
done a great job of building physical uh
hard infrastructure there are a lot of
things that china does
pretty well
and
so that's what that's china's game um
and and the united states needs to be
cognizant of that but also
needs to be thoughtful and measured and
strategic uh and inclusive in in
responding i mean
it can't be the united states versus
china it has to be
a coalition of people all around the
world who share a positive vision
of what we'd like the future
to look like
and then china has a choice to either
join that vision or not and that's why
for example it was so tragic when donald
trump
pulled the united states out of the
trans-pacific partnership in the
earliest days of his presidency because
that's what it was it was a bunch of
countries getting together and said
can we build a model of what we'd like
trade between our countries to look like
and what are the standards
and then once we have that model we'll
have a lot of leverage to china to say
either you meet this standard or not and
that was why i thought it was a great
idea
there was a lot of pressure against it
uh hillary clinton unfortunately uh
during her campaign even though uh
negotiating this had been
according to her one of her
the the things she was proudest of
had in my view erroneously said that she
was no longer for it and then donald
trump withdrew that was a huge victory
for
china and so
um yes you know china is trying to
use your your metaphor you know kicking
a lot of balls at our goal but we're
also uh kicking balls into into our own
goal and we've got to change that one
thing i was thinking about to do with
the popular media representation in
china let's say in their cinema of the
sort of colonialists imperialist like
awful sort of classic western depiction
of americans
i wonder whether that's
ethically much different to how the us
was portraying the classic evil russian
in a a turtleneck and a black cap you
know throughout the 80s because that was
part of the us's rhetoric then yeah it
was i mean certainly looking at who are
the bad guys and how are they portrayed
as is part of just understanding how how
societies function
um and in many ways i think china which
i mean again talk it's about shifting
realities
china is now accusing the united states
of having a cold war mentality uh but
china has had a cold war mentality
against uh the united states even from
the earliest uh the earliest days i'm
just finishing a book called the the
long game by rush doshi and it's pretty
incredible because it looks at
the chinese sources of how
they were articulating what they were
doing and even at the height of u.s of
efforts when the united states was
saying all right we need to integrate
china into the rules-based international
order we need to create a space for them
so that and that over time their society
will evolve and we can work together it
was i'm sure it wasn't so pure as as
that but that's what the story that the
united states leaders were telling
ourselves and i was in government then
but from the chinese sources it was like
these guys want to screw us
we have to sneak in we have to use their
institutions to undermine them i mean
really from day one
according to chinese sources the goal
was
not to to integrate into a global system
for the the mutual good i mean china
thought that that was too beneficial to
the united states um but to uh simulate
engagement with those institutions in
order to undermine and weaken them
china is playing so much of a longer
game
it would feel like than you know it is
the chess versus checkers
analogy was there a um
i feel like i think go go versus check
go versus checkus yeah yeah good way
good way to make it ethnically
appropriate
did i see an interview where you
mentioned that one of the
ideas behind the us
enabling chinese trade was that by
raising living standards and by raising
uh bringing their population out of
poverty the presumption is that
um democracy kind of comes along for the
ride that you have this educated
populous they have better living
standards and then they start to once
they've got food and water and heat and
shelter they start to look at these
bigger questions
but what perhaps we hadn't accounted for
was the power of a very authoritarian
regime with technology to
deploy its means
yeah that's exactly right there were
people like tom carruthers and others
who certainly in the in the later mid to
later 90s we're making this argument
that once people get to be around have
around seven thousand dollars in annual
income
they start to make demands and it forces
governments to change to meet the
demands of those empowered publics
and in my mind it's a little bit of the
arrogance on our side to feel and it was
the same thing with the francis fukuyama
argument about the end of history
they just assume that there's just one
path and we know it and we're on it and
we had that kind of arrogance and and
frankly that arrogance hurt us because
we thought well all we need to do is
help china get rich we just need to open
our systems and we just need to have an
open internet and then the pull the
structural pull of all these is going to
be so transformative that there's
nothing that the chinese government can
do bill clinton had a famous
line we talked about the chinese
internet he's trying to control the
internet he's trying to nail jello to
the wall good luck with that well
china's nailed jello to the wall they've
done actually a great job they've
they've gotten rich
their average income is is above that
level
uh and they they are they are pioneering
just a different model of organization
and in many ways it's working
in some ways for the people who are
living in china as i mentioned
different estimates 700 million people
brought out of abject poverty we talk
about realizing the sustainable
development goals most of that work has
just been done by china not because
the united nations declared these
standards or jeffrey sachs
helped think them up
because the chinese government for its
own purposes
was doing what it wanted to do to
improve
the the well-being and status of china
and the people in in
in china so
um it was it was almost an arrogant view
on our side um and then but so i don't
think that democracy liberal democracy
is in any way inevitable but if we
believe in it if we believe in the
rules-based international order um we
need to think about well how do we grow
it how do we grow it
in an inclusive way and again i'm i'm
american and i'm certainly a you know
patriotic in my way american but
that doesn't mean that i think america
has done everything right we certainly
did a great job of helping
win two world wars and and organize the
world after the after the second and
defended
uh the free world for a long time but
massive flaws massive shortcomings
massive selfishness in terms of our our
use of natural natural resources and
there's a lot to criticize
on all sides and i think we need to we
need to do that and we need to
articulate what's the kind of world that
we'd like to live in
and then try to to build the best path
from here to there
here's the thing man
it may end up being
that a modern society
really struggles to flourish under a
democracy that the i think about this
all the time that the principles of
freedom
genuinely might be some sort of old and
worldy harkback thing that is really
really challenging to wrangle when you
have technology and ubiquitous
communication and all this sort of stuff
now i don't disagree that it makes for a
more flourishing life i think that that
is how you can maximize a human's uh
enjoyment of their days
but we're not talking about that here
we're not talking about enjoyment we're
talking about effectiveness and it may
end up being that an authoritarian
regime like the ccp
is so much more effective
that
without correct checks and balances
without correct sanctions without
correct um foresight and long-term
planning
that
it
they're so much more effective that you
can't compete with them with a
freedom-based society you know i mean
all of the time that's been spent
with political infighting and divisions
in the us if all of that had been put
toward moving in one direction as a
unified front and going together
imagine how much more progress we would
have made now the problem that we have
is because it's a democracy and because
people have freedom they are free to
disagree which causes people to take one
step forward and one step back as
opposed to in china where if you want to
disagree just go do forced labor like
you're you're just unpersoned for a
while and that means that everybody is
moving in the same direction so
yeah that that really concerns me the
fact that freedom may be fundamentally
incompatible with a modern
technologically advanced world when you
have a
ccp like party there competing on a
global scale
yeah so
democracy is not an end in itself it's a
means to the end
of good and accountable governance and
it's got to to deliver and certainly the
argument
that you just made we've heard it before
people were making that argument with
the united states and the soviet union
and especially in the early years how
can we compete when they're all on the
same line they're moving in the same
direction with north and south korea in
the early days
north korea was it was developing faster
than south korea and people were in
south korea were saying how can we
flourish with
with democracy so people have
made that argument repeatedly and
economically when japan was taking off
and they had their famous uh nitty
ministry of industry and and technology
people were saying well how can we with
our our messier
economy uh compete with japan and in all
of those cases uh democracy and open
society flourish and i still believe in
in open societies but that doesn't mean
and connected to biasing before
now that that that that success
is predetermined we've got to make it
happen and we've got to make sure
that our open societies are able to
deliver and that when we talk about open
societies they really are open societies
and that's why we need to make sure at
least here in the united states that our
democracy functions and that's also why
it concerns me so much when i see that
elements of the republican party for
example
um
seem to have a strategy of
disenfranchisement of kind of trying to
reduce the electorate
in order to achieve a different goal and
i'm sure there will be listeners of this
podcast who disagree with that
but
we need to make sure our democracy works
we need to make sure that people feel it
works and we need to make sure that it's
that it's delivering i talked about
china bringing 700 million people out of
abject poverty we don't have 700 million
people here in the united states
we have a lot of people who are living
in abject poverty we have a lot of
people whose life prospects are way less
than other people and we can't afford to
throw people away
there are people now who are being born
in terrible situations slums
who have the potential to be mozart's
and einstein's and john von neumann's
and isaac newton's whatever whatever
whatever you want
but we're not allowing those people the
opportunity to contribute in the ways
that we need them to so i i know open
societies can and hopefully will win in
the end uh but it's not on autopilot
every person has a role to play in
realizing that future
do you think that the chinese citizens
happy
where they are because i'm always struck
by the resilience and the adaptability
of our systems to wherever it is that we
go and very quickly we just become
acclimatized to whatever the environment
is that we're in whether that be
political cultural uh the temperature
that we live in the weather that we live
in as i found coming from the uk out to
texas and
i wonder
what just how
differently
people feel in china you know i mean i i
read the other day that the chinese
government's got gate analysis
technology that's 96 accurate so this
means that a video camera can work out
who you are with a 96 accuracy without
seeing your face simply by analyzing the
biomechanics of how you walk i mean that
is and then social credit system the
tracking of internet basically no state
versus business private all of that
stuff right have you got any idea about
what it's like to be a chinese citizen
living over there under this sort of
regime and the happiness well i mean
certainly i visited china many many
times before i was condemned by the
spokesman of the chinese foreign
ministry from by name from the podium in
beijing so i'm not sure if i can go back
now or ever
but
it's hard to tell because you know on
one hand you know up to 50 million
people are dead as a result of mao's
disastrous policies and and the chinese
communist party
declares publicly all the time that they
are the inheritors of mao's legacy and
so that means most everybody in china
has a relative who's dead because of mao
and and the chinese communist party
everybody recognizes that you can speak
freely but when they do opinion polls
and there's an open question of whether
people are can speak freely people have
a lot of confidence in their government
uh people in china recognize that their
material uh well-being has ma on average
has massively increased compared uh to
their uh to their parents or certainly
to their grandparents who were living in
in abject um in abject poverty so yes
nobody and i i would say nobody likes to
be surveilled to the extent that people
are surveilled in china china as much as
they're spending on national security
spends even more on domestic uh security
and we see no way
they outspend international security
spending internally yes that's crazy
all but factoring in all of those things
are chinese people on average happier or
less happy than people here in the
united states i don't know i mean
certainly there are a lot of reasons for
people in china to be happy and unhappy
and certainly there are a lot of reasons
for people here in the united states to
be happy and unhappy and it sometimes
feels
that there's a lot of energy going into
amplifying
unhappiness and and anger and that's
what stephen pinker
has been kind of the person who's
one of the people who's kind of carried
this this banner it's like hey let's
just look at things we're more educated
healthier
living longer than ever before i mean
things are really just
getting better we do live in an open
society where
we can constantly and we do constantly
throw the bums out and as angry as you
know people on in
on the left were about trump and now
people are on the right are about biden
at least and i hope when we have a
functioning democracy there's there's a
feeling well i'm going to fight for it
but by fight if fight means that we're
gonna go attack the capital and smash
the window and try to
hang the vice president
like that's that's what it looks like in
in banana republics um where you have
you know forced coups or people
manipulate the structures of the
electoral system and and the uh nope and
people don't feel
that governance is legitimate so long
way of saying i believe in open
societies
if we want to keep ours we have to
invest in it because every morning that
we wake up here in the united states
that's the new record for the longest
democracy in human history longest and
so
we don't know how long democracies can
uh can survive maybe there's some
we'll learn in a thousand years there's
an inherent rule of democracies that
they can only last 300 years and it
happens over and over or maybe we'll
learn that democracy as a form uh can
really succeed but it will have to
rejuvenate itself
talk to me about this tennis player that
just got disappeared in china yeah
so
feng shui is a is a very famous uh uh
chinese tennis player she's been in
three olympics and a real
superstar
she then put out a message on on social
media
essentially uh or accusing uh somebody
who had actually had been her her off
and on lover for a decade but who was a
a very very senior uh chinese official
of sexual assault
and then she disappeared um and so there
there's been a big international outcry
uh more recently there was a call set up
between her and the head of the
international olympic committee which
didn't really
really resolve anything so here's how i
i see that issue
it's a big deal in china for a
high-profile celebrity
to make any kind of public claim that's
not aligned with government interests
let alone
to accuse a member of the former member
of the chinese politburo of a sexual
assault
from the chinese government perspective
i think the reason why they move so
aggressively to squash her and her
message
is i think they're afraid of a metoo
movement in china because in china
like in many other countries i can give
you a 100 percent guarantee
that many senior members of the chinese
communist party have assaulted women
over time and abused their power there's
a hundred percent chance of that it's
not just in china it happens in
countries all around all around around
the world if there were
a metoo movement as happened in the
united states in france and in many
other places
the chinese government fears
that
could get out of hand and it's exactly
why with falun gong which is kind of
like a spiritual yoga club and china
attacked them and has imprisoned and
killed many members of of falun gong the
chinese communist party is afraid of any
kind of social organization
not sanctioned by them and they're
afraid of any person
getting the ability to deliver a message
contrary
to the message of the chinese communist
party so that's why jack ma the richest
man in china he criticizes the chinese
government and he vanishes fon bing bing
who's one of the lead actresses is
accused of of not playing by the rules
he disappears and has to come back
much later groveling and asking for
forgiveness we've seen this story over
and over and over and the theme of it is
the chinese communist party
will do anything
to control its narrative and that's the
connection with the covet origin i mean
they have their story
they'll do whatever it takes
to defend their story and that's why
with with feng shui they're willing to
crack down they don't want to lose the
olympics
but it's great that there are people
like ines cantor of the boston celtics
who are who are raising really important
questions and and challenging china
and on covet origins that's why we have
to demand a full investigation just like
we have to
demand that china
be
that if they want to host the olympics
if they want
to get this opportunity to be part of
the international community it comes
with obligations and that's why more
broadly
i've called for every media organization
that's covering the olympics to spend 25
percent of their full media time
covering issues of uh tibet xinjiang
south china sea human rights
in china every corporate sponsor that's
spending on the the the beijing olympics
should spend 10 percent of its full
spend supporting the victims of these
atrocities and whether they're tibetans
uyghurs or investing in in supporting
organizations fighting for democracy in
hong kong and many other situations it
is crazy that china can be a part of a
global movement which is the olympics
sport it's the winter olympics they've
got next year right and um
and yet not play by the rules that the
rest of the world
adheres to or says is fair there is
something
yeah there's something icky about the
entire china situation which
i guess is that
we require them to keep the capitalist
machine moving forward
there is also
perverse incentives
people being monetized you saw that
ridiculous turnaround who was that
wrestler that gave the
oh my god um john cena john cena it was
i actually tweeted against him i mean it
is
let me just use this opportunity to
condemn john cena john cena if you're
listening to this podcast you are a
scoundrel you're supposed to be a tough
guy that's your entire brand and chyna
criticizes you and you get on your hands
and knees and bark like a dog
show some backbone talk to inez cantor
that's what courage looks like standing
up for things standing up for people and
standing up for human rights and i
challenge you john cena to come on this
podcast with me
and let's have the conversation about
china if you think that the chinese
communist party is doing such a great
job if they are supporting human rights
so much that you'll do everything you
can to support them come and and make
that case and let's have a conversation
you heard it john cena uh yeah i mean
it's
man it's so
it's it makes me feel so icky it makes
me feel so uncomfortable generally the
the whole situation around china going
back to uh pong shui and the other
people that kind of get disappeared for
a while what do you think happens do you
think i mean are they being taken away
and tortured are they being taken away
and
what is it that they're not taking away
so the chinese government is very
sophisticated i don't think that feng
shui or jack ma or fon bin bing none of
them were uh were tortured as a matter
of fact i'm certain of it but the
chinese government has a lot of levers
over people like that they can
destroy their lives
they can imprison their
relatives they can take away their means
of making a living of communicating
with their with their fans so they
really have
a lot of of leverage and they're fully
willing to use that leverage when they
feel it's it's necessary including
against other members of the chinese
communist party um who get on on the
wrong side um like uh
well i mean like many of them
and so that's what they're that's what
they're doing and that's frankly why uh
the many scientists who i believe almost
certainly have a lot of relevant
information of the origins of the
pandemic they don't dare speak certainly
they've been threatened by the chinese
government there are laws preventing
them from speaking
but if they speak even if they make a
run for it and and get outside of the
country
and speak uh their families will be in
very significant
danger so this this is a very
thorough control mechanism when you saw
the first photos
of feng shui and she was surrounded by
animals people can google this if they
want to try and see i think she posted
it on wechat which is kind of like
chinese facebook and um
it's the most sinister looking room for
somebody that's been missing for a long
time to arrive in is all of these weird
children's toys on a shelf behind her
and then there's a selfie of her holding
one of them it's
the proper horror movie [ __ ]
and so i have no idea whether that's
actually her room or it's a it's a it's
a movie set but regardless let's just
say that that is her room let's we'll
give china the benefit the doubt
some crew from the chinese propaganda
department came there and set up that as
a photo shoot with you and all of your
soft toys you know it's it's it's just
sinister and it's gross
and we have to be honest about it we
have to condemn it and we have to hold
china accountable
did you see this new ruling that they've
brought in to do with video games for
teenagers
oh yeah no i don't know i did see that
yeah
and so what i will say
is that china looks at other countries
around the region and around the world
like we'll use korea as an example
and then says well here's what we would
like to be like and here's what we don't
want to be like and so we don't want
according to china is a bunch of kids
spending their life playing video games
and we don't want a bunch of young
people modeling themselves after what
what we from a chinese perspective see
as effeminate uh korean movie stars and
so what china does is pass rules this is
the way it should be men should act like
men kids should not watch video games
and and every parent
in the world
faces this kind of thing like when your
kid is on playing video games or on
social media all day or they you know
start wearing funky clothes or whatever
every parent says well maybe we should
have a rule and i just think that with
china
their whole thing is everything i mean
it's it's a country largely ruled by
engineers
they have an engineering for their
government has an engineering philosophy
of life social engineering environmental
engineering the three gorges dam and the
south to north water diversion project
and all these other things everything
can be engineered according to them and
again
that's why those of us who believe in
open societies and i do
we just need to really invest our energy
in making sure that our open societies
can function what does this
masculinizing this manlying of the
chinese population look like this trying
to create a a breed of alpha alpha males
walking around what's going on there
it looks like it i mean when you so i
think it's a contrast what they're
trying to do is contrast to at least
their perception of korean and japanese
men
um and there's just a popular kind of
way of looking for korean movie movie
stars male movie stars in k-pop
that i think china has a lot of disdain
for in japan which had kind of an over
emphasized vision of kind of aggressive
masculinity in the 30s and the first
first half of the 40s now there's a
there's a popular model i can't remember
the exact word but it's something like
vegetarian men
who are these who are perceived and i
would love to vegetarian who are
perceived as these kind of wimpy men who
go to these uh these uh whatever
whatever they're called mistress cafes
or or whatever and
remain virgins until they're 600 years
old or whatever the stereotype is
and i think china
is trying to say well that's not what we
want i mean our model are these you know
rugged um uh
people rugged uh founders of the state
who were engaged in the long march and
again because china's history
the chinese comedy's party's history is
in many ways a fabrication
they have to over invest
in that fabrication and that's why china
every year
they have these massive
world war ii victory parades
and it's true that chinese people fought
in the second world war
but the chinese communist party played a
very minimal role in fighting the
japanese hang on roll it roll it back
for a second
china has a world war ii victory party
every year
yes
what the [ __ ] is it commemorate no no
well i mean lots of countries do that i
mean the united states has it but the
thing is
the chinese entity that spent
a lot of its time and energy fighting
the japanese was the government under
the nationalists of chiang kai-shek the
communists under mao hardly fought the
japanese and what their mission was to
was to maintain
uh their power so they could fight the
communists which they did particularly
after the the second world war so it's
preposterous that the chinese communist
party is celebrating this victory over
the japanese that they didn't play a
significant role
in in bringing about but again it's this
point where china has this kind of
imaginary view and then they work uh to
to try to make it real again like when
the chinese communist party talks about
well china has this ancient civilization
which is absolutely true
but they hardly mention that during the
cultural
revolution
china was destroying its own history it
was burning and destroying its own
manuscripts smashing its greatest art
and and and so in many ways and then
murdering uh so many people representing
uh the older uh the older systems and so
in some ways china is really a startup
nation and there are benefits to being a
a startup nation but
again china has these fake mythologies
and then the government just invests
enormous resources into turning these
fabrications
into things that people feel are real
and maybe every country does that but
china does it at an industrial scale
isn't there a concern about if china was
to invade taiwan that there's quite a
lot of chinese historical artifacts
museums
that would then be part of this
destruction is that right
i don't know if they'd be part of this
destruction but
when chiang kai-shek and the
nationalists
retreated to taiwan in 1949 after they'd
lost the the chinese civil war
they took the treasures the greatest
treasures of chinese civilization with
them which are now part of this
incredible museum in uh in taipei have
you been um i have been it's spectacular
and
um and so china which again under mao
destroyed its own history i mean there
was a lot of great stuff that was left
and and
again the manuscripts were were uh
burned the the treasures of art were
smashed uh the the people who carried
those cultural legacies were ostracized
or or even killed
um and so yeah absolutely so china is
now claiming all of those artworks and
masterpieces from taiwan ironically if
the chiang kai-shek and lots of problems
with chiang kai-shek and the nationals
hadn't taken those masterpieces with
them uh most of them would certainly
have been destroyed
[ __ ] man
i don't know it's um
roll the clock forward for me then roll
the clock forward over the next sort of
10 to 20 years i know that you're not
able to
bring out your clairvoyant
crystals
see what's happening
what do you reckon going to happen
so i don't know what's going to happen
but there are there are some different
options um
and there's some bad options and there
are some good options here's a bad
option uh
china continues its efforts to undermine
the rules-based international order
the rest of the world doesn't do a
sufficient job of fighting back and
standing up for the principles that we
believe in including by making our own
societies stronger and better and we
live in a world
that looks much more
like uh history uh where there is a kind
of a central power a colonial power
that's exerting its influence over uh
over everybody everybody else we've seen
this story
over and over the british did it the
mongols did it the romans did it and
that doesn't mean it's all terrible um
but it means it undermines this again
this post-war liberal international
order that i actually believe in so
that's one there's another uh
story where the rest of the world really
reinvests in open in our open societies
we come together we exert a lot of
influence and we have enough pressure
and influence and unity to give a
message to china you have two options
either to play a more constructive role
in the world or you're just going to be
more and more isolated even though
you're you're a big country and then
china has a a strategic choice
there's a third option which is a very
real
possibility which is war i think war and
military conflict is is on the horizon
you can't have countries building
all of the tools for a massive world war
and just assume it's never going to
happen we're we're moving in that
in that
in that direction
and then there's the fourth and it's the
utopian
one shared world
view is that we all realize that that
there's just a better way to do things
that our human societies has evolved and
that we that
we need to find a way to balance our
narrower interests as citizens of single
countries and consumers of products made
by single corporations and our broader
interests as humans sharing the same
planet where our fates as the pandemic
and climate change and other things have
showed us
are so intimately intertwined um so
i don't think that's going to happen in
10 or
20 years but i certainly hope and that's
why i and we founded one shared world
that there's just a lot of energy of
existing movements like the greta
thundberg and the climate movement and
all sorts of movements we think there's
a unifying principle
which is a recognition of the mutual
responsibilities of our deep global
interdependence and that if we can all
all of these groups and all these people
around the world rally behind those
principles if we can create a strong
enough magnetic field
to draw
people in china who are wonderful people
i think everybody in in china uh most
everybody in china would like to be part
of the world in a constructive way
there's just an issue of governance and
government
then i think that that's a more utopian
version it's going to be harder to
achieve but if we don't
articulate
where we'd like to be we'll never get
there i mean henry david thoreau has a
quote that i use all the time and
embarrassingly it was in my high school
yearbook in kansas city uh which is uh
if you were if you've built castles in
the sky
your work need not be lost that is where
they should be now build the foundations
under them
where should people go they want to read
more about the work that you do oh so i
hope they'll go to my website
jamiemetzel.com
j-a-m-i-e-m-e-t-z-l dot com
there there's links to i have if you
printed out it's 50 pages on pandemic
origins i've written five books and you
can learn about them there my most
recent is hacking darwin genetic
engineering and the and the future of of
humanity but what i
you can why i had a short story a visit
to weisenbaum that was made into a film
and you can watch that short film it's
only 15 minutes on my uh on my website
but jamienetzel.com is the key to
everything else jamie metzel ladies and
gentlemen jamie thank you so much for
today it's been awesome
thanks so much chris really my pleasure
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you